are you a sonic fan then I've got a
bunch of news for you I'm Tony and this
is your superfast gamespot news update a
panel at South by Southwest has given us
new info on this year's upcoming Sonic
games first up sonic mania has been
delayed it was previously slated for
sometime this spring but the window has
now been moved to this summer make sure
you're subscribed to gamespot to be the
first to know when the official release
date is announced Sega has also teased
new enemies pre-order bonuses and the
return of the flying battery zone as for
project sonic 2017 its official name was
revealed as Sonic forces which is meant
to represent the battle between good and
evil some new gameplay was also revealed
showing off the new Hedgehog engine to
no release date has been announced for
forces either but it's due out this year
for ps4 xbox one pc and nintendo switch
for more fast action right now why not
check out our video on how to get near
automatize five main endings
[Music]